say you have these two vectors and you
just want to know how much of these
pointing in the same direction and can I
put a number to it so that may not seem
like a totally natural question for you
yet but come along with me for a few
minutes and you'll start to see how
useful an answer to this question can be
and how the dot products solves this
problem you didn't know you've had but
first we should make this question more
precise vectors have two properties
length and direction but our question is
only about directions so let's forget
about the actual length of the vectors
for now and replace them with vectors of
length 1 that are pointing in the same
direction I'll put a hat on them so that
we remember that we've done this a good
way to interpret this question is how
much does one of these vectors overlap
with the other what I mean is this you
can always write that a hat is equal to
some part in the direction of B hat plus
a bit that's completely perpendicular to
the direction of B why draw a little
triangle like this and then have these
two sides be vectors they add up to the
vector a hat but this bit is in the same
direction as the vector B hat so you can
write it as x times B hat where X is
some number so a hat is equal to x times
B hat plus something that's
perpendicular to B hat this number X
seems like a good answer to our question
because it quantifies how much the a
direction has of the B direction in it
which could be interpreted as the amount
that they're pointing the same way still
that may not convince you so let's do
some examples to help see it imagine
they're pointing exactly the same way
then a hat equals 1 times B hat so X is
equal to 1
but then as it rotates away X gets
smaller this makes sense because they're
less in the same direction then they're
totally perpendicular in the number is
zero again that makes sense
but do you think that the numbers should
get higher or lower if we keep rotating
hopefully you said lower since they're
pointing even less in the same direction
but to check you get it here's a
question suppose that a and B are
pointing in exactly opposite directions
what is X in this case here are the
options and I'd like you to actually
pause the video and put your answer in
the poll some of you might think that
the answer to this is so obvious that
there's no point actually doing it but
trust me putting the effort in to answer
it in the poll will help this stuff
stick in your mind hopefully you said
the answer is minus 1 because a hat is
now minus 1 times B hat so great this
number X seems to be a good answer to
our question because the value of X
decreases as a rotates away from B and
so it measures how much they were
pointing in the same way but we need to
figure out how to calculate it more
easily at this point some of you may
have already started to feel a bit
uneasy you might be seeing some
parallels between this thing that we're
doing now and those unit circles with
right angle triangles they made you draw
in school when you were younger that's
right
there's trigonometry involved
but okay the trig is not so bad so I
want you to figure out which of these
trig formulas is the number x in terms
of the angle theta between a and B pause
the video and figure it out
[Music]
hopefully you guys remembered something
from those many hours in class talking
about right-angled triangles and figured
out that the answer is cos theta so we
have a nice answer to the question how
much the a and B point in the same
direction and even a nice formula for
the answer
cos theta of the angle between them but
how does this relate to the dot product
the dot product is a function that takes
any two vectors a and B of these lengths
and gives you the amount that they're in
the same direction cos theta times their
lens Y tack on the lens doesn't that
ruin the dot products interpretation as
being about how much vectors point the
same way
well we added on because doing that
makes the dot product a linear function
which I'll explain in a sec and later on
you'll see why that's such a boon but
right now I'm going to explain why in an
important situation the dot product is
still very much about how much two
vectors point the same way that
situation is when you have an
orthonormal basis as we know a basis is
just a bunch of vectors that span a
vector space without redundancy in other
words any vector can be written as a
linear combination of the basis vectors
uniquely if you shake you on what any of
those terms meant I explained it in my
video on vectors so go have a look but
okay assuming you're happy with basis
vectors you'll know that these two
vectors are a basis for 2d space but so
are these and even these an orthonormal
basis has two extra properties first
each vector in the basis has to have
length 1 the second is that every vector
in the basis has to be orthogonal to
each other so these things are all
orthonormal bases now by the way if we
had 3d vectors we'd have three basis
vectors and each one of them would have
to be orthogonal to the others
now why would you want an orthonormal
basis because there's so much easier to
work with remember in the vectors video
I said that if you had a 2d basis and
you wanted to find out how to write a
particular vector as a linear
combination of the basis vectors you
could draw this grid and figure it out
from that well if you have an
orthonormal basis it's way easier to do
than that I want you guys to figure it
out for yourself but to make it concrete
say you have this orthonormal basis and
this vector U which has this length you
can write that u equals x times v1 plus
y times v2 I want you to figure out what
X is in particular I want you to write
what X is in terms of the dot product
between U and V 1 I'll put the formula
up for the dot product here if you want
to use it pause the video now because I
think that this is a really useful
question to do yourself first you don't
just want me to tell you the answer
without you trying it because you won't
have learned anything from that
I really hope you tried it but the
answer is one x equals u dot v1 how neat
is that I'll explain why in very quickly
the important thing is that the dot
product is equal to this in this case
because b1 has length 1 then if you draw
this triangle you'll see that U is this
vector in V one's Direction Plus this
vector in b2 s the answer we're looking
for is the length of this bit which you
can figure out is U coz theta which is
the dot product in this case
similarly you can find out the amount of
v2 in you is the dot product of U and V
2 so the dot product in the case of an
orthonormal basis directly tells us how
much of each of the basis vectors to
include or in other words how much u is
pointing in each of the basis directions
this obviously generalizes to when you
have a very big space where there are
many vectors in your orthonormal basis
in every case it allows you to write you
in that basis very neatly this is in my
opinion one of the most important
properties of the dot product and part
of the reason why it's so useful but
here's another reason it's useful the
dot product is linear remember that I
said matrices satisfied this equation
called linearity if not you might want
to watch my video on matrices but it's a
similar thing for dot products if you
want to take the dot product between two
vectors but then you realize that you
can write one of the vectors as a linear
combination of other vectors like this
then it's the same thing to take the dot
product of the original vectors or to
split up the dot product into two parts
like this let's talk about why this is
and why it's very useful in a second but
first I want you to figure out the
answer to this multiple choice question
say you have two vectors a and B and you
want to know what the length of a
projected onto B is in other words the
length of this what is it in terms of
the dot product here are your options
pause now and figure it out
okay well done you've just done your
first homework the reason I got you to
do that one first is because you might
need it for your second homework
question which is to show that the dot
product is linear with a little bit of
help from me I know earlier I said that
I'd show you that the dot product is
linear but it's much better for you to
do it yourself in order to really
understand it I know most of you won't
be used to doing homework from a YouTube
video but please do try it it really
will help you okay so we want to prove
this statement which will simplify to
this for now now there's probably lots
of good ways to prove this but where I
would start is to write U equals a part
in the direction of B and a part that's
orthogonal and do the same for V you'll
need to figure out how big the parts in
the direction of B are once you've done
that though you have all the pieces that
you'll need to put together and I'd love
to see your answers in the comments so
please do try it if you think of another
way to do it I definitely want to see
that too here's one last homework
question and it's to fill in what might
seem like a glaring omission in this
video explaining why this other formula
for the dot product is equal to the one
that I showed you I'll walk you through
proving that but first I want to point
out that this formula isn't actually
always correct it's only correct if the
basis that you are using was orthonormal
but let's assume you have some nice
orthonormal basis to prove this formula
works what I want you to do is first
prove it for a very simple case prove
that it works in the case where the
vectors are the orthonormal basis
vectors themselves so if you took the
dot product of the I and J faces vector
then you could use this formula and get
the right answer
once you've proved that it's up to you
to figure out how to prove it for the
arbitrary case using the linearity
property from the previous question
give it a go and even if you get stuck
please write what you did in the
comments again you might end up with a
different proof from mine in which case
I would love to see that now if you
stuck with me all the way to this point
you seem willing to put in some effort
to understand the more pure mathematical
side of linear algebra I'm really really
glad because that side of this topic is
fantastically rich and beautiful the
next video will explain a bit of that
side of this whole thing so stick around
if you'd like to see that I try upload
these videos two weeks apart but this
one took about seven weeks I've got
excuses though I moved and I've been on
some research visits and I've been going
to this mini film school thing on the
weekends to improve the quality of these
videos all of that is to say I'm really
sorry and it will never happen again
thanks a lot for watching